có se compóul durante la violación am
con matarlatas veces y tamb
orgaser op conunosces conc
permisermin una Manra Pol de la
[Musique]
opiorita su conduaent cont Libert depri
no si
sa en fait Andrea dans ses émissions
avec sa panoplie de terreur est odieux
tu as pas beaucoup d'amis pendant que tu
fais ces films c'est pas un personnage
que tu peux promener c'est pas un
personnage qui fait sorter dans la nuit
avec parce que là là tu es seulle là il
y a plus personne et c'est vrai qu'ils
ont fait très fort les deux complices
Victoria Abril et Pedro Almodovar avec
cette vision cruelle mais lucide d'un
audiovisuel voyeur qui viole la vie des
gens dans une émission intitulée le pire
de la journée dont la productrice
animatrice est Andrea et l'une des
victimes Kika la maquilleuse qui
n'arrête pas de
parler Kika représente pour moi
l'optimisme invincible nécessaire pour
survivre à l'hostilité des grandes
cités et Andrea est le symbole extrême
des grands dangers qui menacent notre
société à travers les moyens de
communication et spécialement les
reality
shows
entre farce et férocité Pedro almovar
met en scène le viol le plus long du
cinéma je crois que j'ai une vision très
romantique de la
vie une provocation une contradiction de
plus pour alov c'est peut-être pour
cette raison que Victoria
l'AIM